you know you've worked on psych for 37
over over that
uh many years
have you ever considered
quitting
i mean has it been too much so
i'm sure there's an optimism in the
early days that this is going to be way
easier
and let me ask it another way too
because i've talked to a few people on
this podcast ai folks
that bring up
psych is an example of a project
that has a beautiful vision
and it's a beautiful dream
but it never really materialized
that's how it's spoken about
um
i suppose you could say the same thing
about yellow networks and all all ideas
um until they are
so what um
why do you think people say that first
of all
and second of all did you feel that
ever throughout your journey did you
ever consider quitting
on this mission we keep a very low
profile
we don't
attend
very many conferences we don't give
talks we don't write papers we don't
play the academic
game
at all and as a result
people often only know about us because
of a paper we wrote 10 or 20 or 30
or 37 years ago
they only know about us because of what
someone else second hand or third hand
said about us so thank you for doing
this podcast by the way sure it it uh
shines a little bit of light on some of
the fascinating stuff you're doing well
i think it's time for us to keep a
higher profile
now that we're far enough along that
other people can begin to help us
with the
the final n percent maybe n is maybe 90
but
now that we've gotten this knowledge
pump primed
it's going to become very important for
everyone to help if they are willing to
if they're interested in it
retirees who have enormous amounts of
time and would like to leave some kind
of legacy
to the world
people because of the pandemic who have
more time
at home or for one reason or another on
to be online and contribute if we can
raise awareness of how far our project
has come and how close to being
primed the knowledge pump is
then we can begin to harness
this untapped amount of humanity i'm not
really that concerned about
professional colleagues opinions of
our project i'm interested in
getting as many people in the world as
possible actively helping and
contributing to get us from where we are
to really covering all of human
knowledge and different human opinion
including contrasting opinion that's
that's worth representing so i think
that's that's one reason um
um a i i don't think there's there was
ever a time where i thought about
quitting
there are times where i've become
depressed a little bit about how hard it
is to get funding for the system
occasionally there are ai winters and
things like that
occasionally there are
ai
but you might call summers
where people have said why in the world
didn't you sell your company
to um you know company x for um some
large amount of money when you had the
opportunity and so on and you know
company x here are like old companies
maybe you've never even heard of like
lycos or something like that
so
the the answer is that one reason we've
stayed a private
company we haven't gone public one
reason that we haven't
gone out of our way to take investment
dollars
is because we want to have control over
our future over our state of being so
that we can continue to do this as until
it's done and we're making progress and
we're now so close to done that almost
all of our work
is commercial applications of our
technology so five years ago almost all
of our money came from the government
now
virtually none of it comes from the
government almost all of it is from
companies that are actually using it for
something hospital chains using it for
medical reasoning about patients
and
energy companies using it and
various other you know manufacturers
using it to reason about supply chains
and things like that
you